Hey, sit down, and I'll tell you a story.
My name is Arthur.
I'm seven years old, and my life is great.
Every morning Mom wakes me up by tickling my feet.
It makes me laugh and starts my day on a happy note.
For breakfast, Dad makes Mickey Mouse shaped pancakes.
After school, Dad and I kick the ball until dinner.
For dessert, I always have a huge cookie with milk.
I have my own special cup from Disneyland.
But a few months ago, my parents told me some bad news.
They said that I'm going to have a little sister.
I know I'm not going to like it.
I have never had to share my parents with anybody.
My friend Jeff got a baby sister last year.
His parents never have time to play with him.
And they are always busy changing the baby's stinky diapers! Yuck!
Mom and Dad said that I will have to share my bedroom with the baby.
She better not use my Disneyland cup.
No way.
I told Mom that I don't want a baby sister.
But that didn't seem to matter.
Today, Mom and Dad are coming home with my new sister.
I'm just going to tell them to take her back.
I don't want to share my mom and dad, or my room.
Well, here they are.
Dad is carrying some pink blankets.
Is the baby inside there?
Is she that small?
Grandma goes outside.
She hugs Mom and then looks inside the pink blankets.
I hear Grandma say the baby is beautiful.
I'm not going out there.
I'm going to sit right here.
Now Mom is hugging me.
Dad puts the baby in my lap.
And then, the most amazing thing happens.
She reaches out and grabs my finger!
She won't let go!
I think she knows that I'm her big brother.
She likes me already.
Hey, maybe having a sister won't be so bad.
I think Mom and Dad have enough love for both of us.